heute sehr interessant wird die ehefrau
vom angeklagten gasse aus schotter
gehört werden hat er flüchtete mit ihren
zwei kleinen kindern nach dänemark im
winter 2017 2018 und dort soll arafat
und jasser aufgetaucht sein und die
beiden kinder der mutter entzogen haben
und zurück nach deutschland gebracht
haben daraufhin soll patina und arafat
angezeigt haben wegen kindesentziehung
und hat auch dem lka ausgesagt dass
angeblich hat die entführung der fünf
burschen geplant haben soll
sie hat mittlerweile die aussage
zurückgenommen
man munkelt sie hat ein schweigegeld von
nach vielleicht sogar 50.000 euro dafür
bekommen dass sie jetzt die aussage
zurück nimmt ich gehört habe wird sie
heute möglicherweise aufgrund der
gefährdungslage und sie ist die cousine
von aller ford augusta ihr
zeugnisverweigerungsrecht vor gericht
erklären
am ersten tag sind die angeklagten ja
relativ medienwirksam durch den
haupteingang reingekommen wie sieht das
heute aus sind welche vom plan schon da
hast du arafat abou chaker oder seine
brüder bereits gesehen und wenn ja wie
sind sie heute vor gericht vor gefahren
ja heute hier vor dem hauptportal hat
sich bislang keiner blicken lassen es
gibt eine möglichkeit um in das haus ein
zu kommen die wahrscheinlichste
möglichkeit wird sein dass die
angeklagten ihren anwälten zusammen über
des akkus über die zufahrt in das
gerichtsgebäude gekommen sind und hier
hat sich heute morgen noch keiner der
angebotene abo schalter oder deren
freunde eingefunden